good day and welcome i'm jack van horn from the
university of virginia and i'm proud to welcome
you to this edition of our 2021 2022 foundations
biomedical data science seminar series this
lecture series is supported by uva's integrated
translational health institute of virginia the uva
brain institute the college of arts and sciences
the school of data science and through a grant
from the national institutes of general medical
sciences this year's theme is ethical challenges
of artificial intelligence and biomedicine where
we enjoy presentations on fridays from leading
thinkers about the promise opportunities and the
hurdles associated with ai applications in the
biomedical sciences selected participants in our
biomedical data science innovation lab program
will help we'll leverage these presentations
as vital material for our culminating in-person
grant project workshop to be held here in
historic charlottesville virginia next june
it is my delight and honor today to welcome our
speaker dr caitlin wiley from the university of
virginia caitlin received her phd from cambridge
university and she is here at the university
of virginia's school of engineering and applied
sciences where she is an assistant professor uh
as a social scientist she investigates the
ways in which people create interpret data
design research tools techniques and construct
knowledge in the sciences and engineering
she uses interviews and participant observations
to study overlooked collaborators on research
teams such as technicians students and volunteers
and she teaches engineering students how to assess
the social and ethical dimensions of the
technology and professional work they are doing
so they can be designed as safely equitably and
successfully in terms of socio-technical systems
uh as safely as possible we are proud to say that
caitlin is also serving as one of our 2021-2022
biomedical data science innovation lab mentors
and caitlin's lecture today is entitled ethical ai
requires ethical collaboration collaboration being
a crucial part of science and yet um respectful
knowledgeable um and integration is a challenge
to achieve and in her talk she's going to discuss
the frameworks for thinking about research as a
collective endeavor and practical strategies for
supporting ethical team science including how to
craft group identity how to foster an inclusive
environment and how to translate knowledge
across disciplines as always we are streaming
this lecture live and for recording via youtube
and if you are watching on youtube thank you so
much for joining us today and also our specially
selected 2021 2022 biomedical data science
innovation lab participants are encouraged to
submit any questions for caitlyn via the chat
feature in their zoom sessions i will personally
synthesize these questions and ask them on
your behalf during the last 10 minutes or so for
lecture and without further ado we welcome caitlin
thank you so much caitlin we are super excited to
hear from you today thanks jack thanks everyone
yeah as jack said i really want to make a broader
argument than ai in particular and you can replace
ai in this title with research or science or
technology in the sense that we can't do anything
we can't make any ethical products without
an ethical process and so i want to make the
argument that a crucial part of ethical research
process is collaboration and so in this photo
and that's me in the middle in the green jacket
i'm being an ethnographer um in a research lab
in the field of vertebrate paleontology so that's
you might think that's pretty different from ai
and medical research and going to disagree and
suggest what we can learn from a variety of
fields that can inform how we can build ethical
ai together across disciplines across cultures
so in this photo there are scientists
they're technicians there are volunteers
there's a social scientist right there's various
things with which people make knowledge about
extinct animals and so i want to think about
collaboration in terms of a broader sense of
who is doing the research not just the scientists
not just the pis but really everybody in the room
so first of all let's think a little
bit about what we mean by collaboration
i'm sure you've seen some of these words
they're very trendy especially among funders um
and i want to think about yeah my scientists
and engineer collaborators get caught up on
like what the differences are between these words
i think that's less important than the assumptions
behind these words so let's think about what it
means to be interdisciplinary transdisciplinary
multidisciplinary it assumes that everyone
belongs to a discipline which is not always true
right as someone who does science technology and
society as a field and i belong to a lot of
disciplines and the idea that we are working
across them suggests that we already belong to
one okay so there are limitations with that view
these terms also assume that everyone is
separate okay we are co-producing so again
the idea that disciplines are separate bodies
of knowledge and of people um and that can be
a barrier by assuming that these disciplines and
groups of people actually don't overlap already
and then finally these words and especially their
trendiness right the nsf is very pro-convergence
research for example and it assumes that science
is not already an extremely collaborative endeavor
and so that made me wonder like who
who counts then as a collaborator who
are we assuming is a collaborator when
we take these frameworks of convergence
and co-production and cross-cutting
initiatives what is new about them
so generally if we're asking who we consider
to be collaborators these are the groups
so scientists or people like me researchers have
have great respect for other people with phds and
so you generally would count them as collaborators
technicians varies a lot by field in some fields
of biomedicine technicians have phds and our
authors on publications and other fields like
vertebrate paleontology and technicians do not
have a shared credential some of them don't have
a college degree they are not considered authors
on papers and their work is considered to be very
separate from the research itself so this is a
disciplinary difference that can get in the way of
interdisciplinary collaborations and then
of course students are a really interesting
example because everyone thinks it's good
to have students involved in research um
but whether they're seen as learners or as
collaborators differs a lot based on the
context and on the discipline so sometimes you
you see professors sort of tempting students to
join their labs so that the students can have a
paper so they can be an author on a paper sort of
someday after putting in years of effort and
if they contribute enough epistemic you know
intellectual um material to that paper and so
how you define that is really squishy and hard to
standardize and the same goes for volunteers
so some fields of research rely on citizen
scientists or amateurs paleontology is one
of them um and yet rarely are they considered
contributors in the same way that students
or technicians or especially researchers are
instead they're considered kind of an outreach
effort or maybe like free labor that's kind of
nice but not actually contributing knowledge and
that's wrong as i'm going to show you through some
examples and then finally research participants
are not considered collaborators generally they're
considered like the the subjects of the research
which is not a very fair way to think about them
and of course community members so
all the rest of us who are around
these research projects or even living
in the site of research projects
and we are usually considered the context
the background not part of the research team
and so i'm going to challenge some of
these assumptions and ask us to think
more broadly about who we should consider
collaborators by looking at these particular
categories of collaborators through
some examples from my research
so basically my argument is if we recognize how
all of these people contribute to scientific
research we'll learn a lot about how diverse
perspectives and experiences help us make
sense of the world together right do better
research and how we can do that better and so
i would suggest that there's a moral argument
to this more inclusive view of collaborators
and there's a practical argument that we will
make better knowledge when we work together
so here are some theories i want to
think with i use these a lot across
various projects that i work on the first is a
community of practice and so this is the idea
that we define a community based on the work
that they do their their practice their shared
efforts as opposed to their disciplinary
identity or their credentials
because this is more focused on the work and less
focused on the past okay so it acknowledges that
people can have awesome expertise that
they bring to the table regardless of
what degrees they have and so this has this theory
relies on a notion of learning that is in situ
sort of an apprenticeship model of learning
social norms and technical practice which i
think is very true in cutting edge research
when you know nobody knows how to build
ethical ai and so we're all learning how to
do it together from each other by doing it
another theory i work with a lot is
called standpoint theory this comes from
feminist thought and it's the idea
that if we're all standing in a valley
you know our geographic standpoint our perspective
is different from everyone else's nobody can
share the same view of this valley that we're
overlooking and therefore it's valuable to have
people standing around a problem if you think
of it that way because they're all going to
bring different experiences different
ways of understanding that problem
physically a different perspective right based
on their identities and what their lives have
been like and this diversity enriches knowledge
makes knowledge better to have a variety of inputs
and then finally there's a lovely way of thinking
about expertise that points out that those you
know an insular team a community of practice that
ignores outsiders um is missing out on all of the
wisdom that comes from being an outsider okay we
all get a little narrow in our in our perspectives
when we're with people who are doing the same
things as us or people we've worked with a long
time and we forget to consider what it's like to
look at our team from the outside and so etienne
wenger calls this a wisdom of peripherality
okay so the wisdom that comes from being outside
of a community of practice and i think that's
incredibly important for ethical ai in particular
because the implications of it are going to be
broad and therefore we need to have outsiders
right supposed non-experts like community
members and we need their perspectives
all right so how do we learn
about ethical collaboration
by looking at the kinds of collaborators
that we often overlook so as jack said i am
an ethnographer i use participant observation and
interviews in my research so that means i hang out
in research communities and talk to people
about what it's like to do their work and the
three cases i'm going to talk about today
are technicians invertebrate paleontology
undergrads who work in engineering labs and
community members who partner with my research
team to study the effects of climate change on
their infrastructure in their town in alaska
all right so let's start with those technicians
the way that scientists think about technicians
tends to be in two veins one is they're part of
the machine okay they're part of the laboratory
equipment as you can see from some of these quotes
and that technicians the value of technicians is
being able to be replicable they just need to
do the experiment in a way that other people can
achieve the same results um so this is one
way okay this is sort of grunt work they're
very technical they're just meant to follow
instructions and yet if you've ever done research
you know this is deeply untrue that often it's
the technicians who are the only ones who know
how to make that machine give the results that
you want or the only ones who know how to fix
something when things go wrong and and so this
sort of mechanical view of technicians is really
ignoring their expertise and so the image on the
right is a fossil preparator holding a tiny drill
so the thing she's holding is vibrating and it's
removing the rock from this gorgeous fish fossil
and you can imagine like how on earth could
this be mechanical the level of artistry it
takes to remove a very thin layer of rock
without damaging the bones underneath and
is incredible and has nothing to do with
being part of the machine so this sort of
dismissive view of technicians is not only wrong
but offensive and so the other way that scientists
tend to view technicians and this is how they talk
about them right scientists know that their work
relies on the value of their technicians
the expertise of their technicians they
just don't talk about it in formal senses like
in papers in some fields um but scientists know
and so they say things that like that technicians
have lab hands or instinct okay there's something
unnameable to their skill that is very um
hands-on skill based rather than credential based
so yeah for vertebrate paleontology in particular
fossil preparators talk a lot about creative
problem solving that their work really isn't is
an endless stream of problems that they have to
um approach so like every fossil is individual um
every kind of rock is a little bit different every
tool is going to work differently on every rock
and so there's a lot of creativity and problem
solving and tinkering and tool design that makes
their work possible of making the fossil visible
visible for the scientists to study and so if
you've read hope jaron's 2016 bestseller lab girl
um it's about her career as a
paleobotanist and it's really
um a love letter to her technician bill whom
she takes with her across various institutions
throughout her academic career because she
knows that her research and her success
as a professor um depend on bill's expertise and
support and friendship and so i thought that was
a wonderful sort of best-selling memoir view
of the actual role of technicians in research
i wrote a whole book about technicians this
book is not actually about dinosaurs as you
as may be confusing from the title and this is
available open access on the mit press website
if you want to know more about how to think
about creativity and manual skills in research
all right so let's think about undergrads so
universities tout undergraduate research we all
think it's good right it's an inherent
good it's got to be good for students
um and part of this comes from a perspective of
professionalization and training and developing
lab skills through learning by doing learning in
a community of practice and this is evident in
the way that the nsf for example portrays research
experiences for undergraduates or reu programs as
educational grants they're not research grants
which is interesting because it's really paying
a student to work in the lab for a summer and so
i found in my studies of engineering labs that
actually undergrads are contributing a lot to the
knowledge and social community and and learning
of lab communities okay they're not just sort
of passive recipients of what it's like to be
in a lab which you know they're learning that
too but they're also contributing back in ways
that are not recognized and are actually
amazing um so let me tell you some examples
so in one summer for one summer a
biomedical engineer was placed in
an electrical engineering lab she was not
happy about this she felt very out of place
and she didn't really know anything
about electrical engineering
except that this lab was building sensors
to try to measure stress in in patients
and so the pi of the lab was saying
to the lab group of you know 15 to 20
students in a room he was saying how can we
measure stress you know what about cortisol can we
measure cortisol like he doesn't know he's either
he's an electrical engineer and the undergrad says
well no cortisol is not a good indicator of stress
because it changes over the course of the day it
changes based on what the person is doing it's
not a reliable indicator of whether the person
is experiencing stress and the pi in the whole
room shuts up to hear this undergrad explain this
because they don't know okay she's bringing
knowledge from another field she's bringing
knowledge from her broad education as an undergrad
as opposed to grad students and pis who have
become very narrow become very specialized and she
was opening back up engineering knowledge for them
another example was from a student who was part of
a robotics club and so he learned how to 3d print
parts for this robotics club and he also worked
in a research lab and the lab was building sensors
that were going to be put outside and they were
trying to debate how to protect the sensors and
the students said well why don't we 3d print a
casing and they were like can we do that and so
the student ended up designing and printing the
casings for these sensors that were the basis of
the research lab's research so it's an incredible
contribution not only of like an idea that came
from outside the lab but also the skills to know
how to do it because no one no one else in the
lab knew how to 3d print anything and then when
that student left graduated it was interesting
because the lab really scrambled because they
didn't have anyone to replace those skills
and then finally undergrads play this really
interesting role in engineering research labs and
universities um in the sense that they get really
good at particular things so again this grunt work
idea of technicians and students washing
glassware you know doing repetitive experiments
and that that's boring and easy and therefore
the more junior people in the lab should do it
and yet undergrads would become so good
at these supposedly menial tasks that the
results would be better okay so later on down the
research process the results were better when a
particular undergrad prepared the reagent and
and then that re when that skill was recognized
or when that contribution was recognized and pis
would sometimes say to grad students or to other
students you know go and learn that technique
from this undergrad because they really do it well
so in that sense undergrads are
taking this skill this task that is
supposedly boring and routine and easy and and
making visible the expertise that it relies on
and they're then passing on that knowledge to
other people in the lab so they're creating
learning opportunities for
the grad students for the pi
and then finally i've seen
lots of examples of undergrads
coming up with ways that their research teams
could use their methods and for other applications
so for example in the electrical engineering lab
they are really great at building low-cost sensors
and so usually they do these for healthcare
purposes and like patient monitoring purposes
and one undergrad said well why don't
we use them for air pollution monitoring
you know we already measure indoor environments
why couldn't we just put one on a stop light
put a sensor system on a stop light and use it
to predict asthma risk for example based on the
quality of the air and everybody else in the lab
thought this was brilliant like what a great idea
okay so again this undergrad ability to think
big and think outside of what might be expected
within a particular lab or a particular discipline
and it's this is real intellectual contribution
and so i want to talk a little more about how
undergrads create space for others to learn
because again we assume that undergrads are the
learners here and actually in my research i'm
finding that they are not the only learners
when an undergrad is present everybody else
learns a lot more and part of that is because
undergrads are expected to be learners so they
can ask supposedly dumb questions right that
no one expects them to know how things work
but most of the time i see
undergrads ask questions in
in lab meetings for example all the grad students
become really quiet because they want to know the
answer okay and they might have too much in
you know too much in the game too much skin
in the game they don't want their pi to know
that they don't actually know how that machine
works or why that result looks that way or why
we make graphs in this way and so undergrads
reopen these assumptions in ways that are really
helpful for the graduate students in particular
also i've seen undergrads ask questions
about how things work that then the
researchers pause and say i don't know why
we do things this way let's try your way
right or i don't know why this is obviously
data this reading and this one is obviously
noise i'm going to reject this one and i'm
it's really hard for me to explain to you why
and i've seen research really sit down for a few
minutes and like analyze their own assumptions
and this reflective work is going to make the
research better it's making the practitioners
slow down and think through what they're
doing so that they can explain it to the
undergrad and that's going to make them more
responsible more careful in their research
and then finally many professors use undergrads
as judges for grad students conference talks for
example like grad students are often practicing
talks learning how to give presentations in group
meetings and at the end the pis will turn to the
undergrads and say like how did that go for you
how well did you understand that because they
value the undergrad's perspective as a general
listener right they're not the undergrads are
not expected to be an expert in that field and
the grad students are supposed to be talking at
an audience level that's probably about
equivalent to an undergrad because people in
the audience at the conference will be experts
in various different things and so undergrads
are considered sort of the ideal audience for
practice talks which i think is really interesting
and so in that sense it's sort of valuing the
undergrad's ignorance in a way okay the undergrads
ability to understand what is comprehensible
what is clear about that explanation
as opposed to somebody who already understands
the field and and assumes that they know
so this is an image a photo of um this
grad student with the purple gloves
the machine wasn't working right um this is a
machine that saws samples in material science
and the undergrad was saying um what's wrong
like is it supposed to work like this and the
graduate student stopped and had to like take it
all apart to figure out why it was working the
way that it was and what the problem was and so
both of them got to learn how that machine worked
um really because the undergrad said
you know should it be making that noise
and then of course undergrads offer the
opportunity for others to learn how to mentor
how to collaborate how to communicate because
you know the undergrads are around they need
someone to sort of watch over them and
so grad students and professors learn
by doing in that sense and they couldn't
do that if the undergrads were not there
and then a lot of grad students and professors
talk about undergrads as motivating that they're
the undergrads are so happy to be there and
they're really excited about the research
and that the grad students feel sort of
uplifted and even the pi's will say it's
so fun when so and so student comes to lab
meetings because they bring a lot of energy
so my argument here is that undergrads are
not the only learners in these communities
and that really everybody benefits when
we include students and research teams
for the students intellectual contributions
for their contributions of skillful labor
and for their ignorance basically their broad
education their lack of specialization their
lack of assumptions about a particular
field and that those are really helpful
for helping the experts think through what
they're doing and explain what they're doing
okay finally so
community members are a really interesting
case in the ethics of collaboration
because sort of the field of community-based
research and community engaged research is growing
in really interesting ways so i think i think
we can all see arguments for why technicians
and students should be considered collaborators
for their sort of classic epistemic contributions
and community community members is a little
harder it's a little harder for us to understand
so let me talk you through a case in
which our research will be a complete
failure if we cannot collaborate ethically
responsibly effectively with community members
so i'm on a team um that got an nsf award through
the navigating the new arctic program which
is one of the nsf's 10 big ideas if you've been
following the nsf's um research sort of priorities
and the goal is to study an urban setting
and to see how climate change is interacting
with infrastructure built infrastructure
urban we're studying utkahvic alaska
which is the northernmost city in the united
states you can see at the top of this map it's
that red dots the very tip of alaska on the
north slope there's about 4 000 people there
who live there they're majority
indigenous alaska native
and to to understand how their infrastructure
is being affected by climate change and and
the reverse how the local environments are being
affected by the infrastructure that they've built
we absolutely rely on them not only are they
living you know with that infrastructure day
in and day out and they also are drawing
on about twelve thousand years worth of
human occupation at utk and so lots of indigenous
knowledge lots of traditional knowledge lots of
just a massive archive of climate
knowledge and how to adapt to it
so we are showing up and with the machines in
this photo this is my collaborator matthew joel
who's in uva's architecture school and he's
building a sensor tower with some students
in charlottesville and this sensor tower has
all kinds of micro meteorological sensors so
um they can measure precipitation and temperature
and solar radiation and lots of other things
and so the idea is we're going to plant
these at various points in newt kyogvik
to observe what happens between infrastructure
and the local environment over the next five years
and so we are a team of environmental
scientists and architects and social scientists
and you can see i put the the residents of
kyogre on our author list because we can't
do this without them and really we're doing
this for them we hope to get knowledge for
environmental science and social science
and architecture but really our hope is to
study how infrastructure and the environment
interacts so that we can give some design
guidelines to the city of ukayogvik in terms
of where they should develop where they should
build where is the permafrost most stable
which design of housing best resists the wind
um how can we best build structures to prevent
coastal erosion right utk is right on the ocean
so yeah we this is this project in service of them
and we also hope that all of our
fields will learn from it too
so let's talk a little bit about arctic climate
change so ukiyoga is in the arctic circle and
and this is what happens when permafrost thaws
you can see that the road on the left is all wavy
roads in alaska are mostly built on gravel
not cement because the ground moves so much
that the gravel is more sort of forgiving
and but still this is a dangerous road and
especially if it changes enough that it opens
up a chasm a pothole and it's really unsafe
particularly when there's ice which
is most of the year new chaotic
also structures start to fail because the ground
underneath them is is softening right thawing away
and then this is what the ground looks like when
permafrost thaws and all the water that was locked
into frozen soil and also all the carbon um
is released when that permafrost thaws and so
then we get these very weird called thermo-carce
very weird geological formations that are tough
to build on and water moves in unexpected ways
so there's issues with flooding there's issues
with salt water coming into the freshwater
ponds that utilize uses for drinking water
so lots of infrastructural issues um throughout
the city also another issue that the arctic
has that most of us don't you know have the
privilege of not worrying about is oil pipelines
so there are a lot of pipelines in alaska and
also in siberia in the siberian arctic so here's
um here's here's okay big
and so one of the main problems with permafrost
thaw is that pipelines can become broken or
unstable and then there can be fires this has been
a major problem across siberia and across alaska
so here are some ways in which and the
community is already adapting as i said
and people have lived in newt kyogvik for over
12 000 years so they have deep expertise about
how to survive in this arctic climate um except
that it's changing faster than it ever has before
so we're learning a lot our team is learning
a lot about resilience and cultural resilience
from um especially the indigenous members the
indigenous residents of kyogre and so for example
this picture on the right is the
utk coastline you can see the beach
there's the arctic ocean gorgeous gorgeous city
and and so okiyagik used to be a major oiling
oil center for the united states there used
to be a lot of money nutyag as a result
and so these are old rail cars you can kind of
see that these are rail cars buried in the sand
and this is to prevent coastal erosion caused
by sea level rise all right so that the ocean
stays on that side of these train cars to
protect the city which is on the other side
so what an amazing example of reuse and making
do with what you have because dude kyogre
is remote it's hard to get things there
you have to fly basically all supplies in
by airplane it's very expensive and so they took
basically trash right and these abandoned rail
cars probably from the oil boom and repurposed
them as a way to hold their beach in place
brilliant and then on the left are pictures
of our team um deploying ground penetrating
radar beneath the house in kyogre so all the
houses all those buildings in the new kyogre are
um sort of five or so feet off the
ground to try to keep them warmer
right you don't want to build right on permafrost
because it'll suck all the heat out of your house
and so we're spending a lot of time crawling
beneath people's property with ground penetrating
radar lines and to measure the the permafrost
below and see where is rock where is ice
and again people are very concerned about their
houses collapsing and again the cost of living
is very high in kyogrik and people cannot afford
um to pick up their house and move it right or to
build a new foundation because the foundation is
melting so this is very much like how do we help
them now situation as well as how do we plan
for future changes caused by climate change
so again this is this is a moral
argument and an an epistemic one
so it is more ethical to work with communities in
all cases than to assume that we are serving them
or acting in their interest right nothing about
us without us from the disability justice movement
applies to all communities and and of course
people who live in kyogre have sovereignty over
their knowledge their indigenous knowledge their
traditional knowledge their experiential knowledge
their expertise right of living in this
climate and they have sovereignty over
their land particularly indigenous sovereignty and
the movement and data ethics is towards indigenous
sovereignty over their data so that means that any
data that we collect on their land on residents
land belongs to them and not to us and so this
seems sort of obvious when you put it that way but
it's very different from the previous
research traditions where scientists show up
do a bunch of measurements and leave right and and
leave nothing behind for residents don't produce
knowledge that the residents can use sometimes
don't even share their results with residents
or they're studying science just
for science's sake rather than
for anything that would be
useful to living in the arctic
and so our team is facing really
interesting challenges about how
to respect indigenous data sovereignty
how to collect data that are useful
for people who live there and accessible not only
because the internet access is very challenging
but also comprehensible right if we don't have
a lot of data scientists living in kyogre how
do we make this data relevant for them how can
we display it for example what kind of dashboard
of temperatures across the
city might be useful for them
and of course this is particularly hard to do
because ut kyogre is very overstudied it has an
airport so basically all people who are studying
the american arctic do studies in new cayogic
just because it's more accessible than some of the
more remote villages and so there's a long history
of exploitation by scientists so what we call
parachute science where people arrive take their
samples take their data sometimes they take social
science data like interviews with people who live
there and then they disappear okay so again if
we're arguing that the indigenous sovereignty of
land extends to data this is a serious moral and
ethical and responsibility and you know mistake
so we need to overcome those challenges
first of all the history of exploitation
and crucially we can do better science
with the community member's help
and so for example we are really interested in
permafrost characterization so that means like
what is the permafrost made of is it mostly
soil is it mostly water is it rock and how
do we understand that what can we actually see
with the ground penetrating radar data and our
collaborators in new kyogre who are various um
civil organizations as well as some individual
sort of residents private residents they said
well we don't really care about that but what
we'd really like to know is how do we save our
ice sellers so utki avec is a whaling culture and
they collect whales in the fall in the spring
and store them in ice sellers which our sellers
dug into the permafrost and they've been doing it
this for thousands of years and the ice sellers
are now thawing along with the permafrost and so
the whale meat is spoiling and this is not only
a loss for subsistence living which most people
knew kyogrik practiced subsistence whaling and
subsistence hunting and gathering and the loss
of the ice cellar is also a major cultural blow
because the whale is a crucial part of the
sort of world view of the anupiak culture
and the ice sellers are considered to be the
whale's home on land so the whale gives themselves
to the whalers the whalers take the whale home to
the ice seller and so if the ice seller is thawing
it's a disaster it's a sign of disrespect to
that whale and so there's intense cultural loss
um in these sort of apparently simple forms of
infrastructure and so then we so we tried to
change our research questions to be more about
what is it about permafrost that preserves meat
because the the town of it kyogre bought some sort
of industrial deep freezers and put whale meat in
there and they said it doesn't taste as good it
doesn't work it doesn't meet the cultural sort of
significance of the ice sellers there's something
chemical that's happening in them not just
freezing it's not just about temperature
and so that's actually a really fascinating
question scientifically as well as with deep
cultural meaning for our partners in new chaotic
another instance in which we are reliant on
their expertise is trying to decide where
we're going to put all of our sensors and where
we should do ground penetrating radar surveys um
which really relies on asking the residents
where have you seen the ground move where
have you seen flooding whose house is crooked
okay those are all indicators that they know
that can help us decide where we can watch the
most things happen and it's sort of horrible
to sort of watch someone's house fall down and
but again the hope is that we'll learn from that
failure how to build better how to build
structures that are going to be more resilient
and of course our our residents our partners have
a very challenging role to play which is to stop
us when we're wrong and so we showed up you know
saying we're going to bring ground penetrating
radar we're going to do these surveys of the
permafrost to tell you where it's safe to build
and isn't this great and they said
you know we have 12 000 years worth
of archaeology underneath us you can't run
ground penetrating radar over our sacred sites
so thank goodness right thank goodness they were
kind enough and respectful enough to stop us and
to tell us where those sites are because we
certainly don't want to do them any harm right
and or do them any disrespect and so we would
have done bad science we would have done
offensive insulting science without their
guidance and they didn't have to do that
right they could have just said no instead
they said we have this concern here's a map
avoid these areas which is going
to make our research much better
okay so i just want to bring some
of this together to argue that
understanding research teams as communities of
practice is more inclusive than disciplines right
if we're all doing the work together alongside
each other we're all learning we're all coming
up with new ideas we're all correcting each other
and that that's the best way to build a community
and then i hope you've seen that
incorporating diverse standpoints such as
people who have a variety of education
levels and including none at all in science
produces more comprehensive reliable
respectful and useful knowledge
and also everyone who participates
in research contributes knowledge
and community building and opportunities for
learning so i think we i think we're easy it's
easy for us to say yeah collaborators contribute
labor they contribute more than that even if
it's hard for us to recognize they absolutely
do even the undergrads sitting in the lab and
telling jokes is lifting everybody's spirits
bringing everybody more together bringing a
sense of community building and that's
really crucial to knowledge production
and then of course this idea of
peripheral wisdom which i love that
we need outsiders to tell us when we're
in the wrong and when we're in the right
so that if so then that takes me back to my
original question which is who then should count
as a collaborator ethically normatively
who should we consider to be collaborators
i hope the answer to this is
obvious and that it's everybody
so then let's move back to ethical ai
or ethical research ethical science
ethical technology what does this
mean in practice what can we do
so i would contend that we can't build
ethical technology or ethical knowledge without
ethical collaborations it's the first crucial step
and so some ways to do that are appreciate
technicians right if we pay them more if
we say thank you if we make them authors if
that's what they're interested in being and
they're going to be more committed they're going
to stay in that lab they're going to work harder
okay they're going to think more deeply about what
they're doing all of which is good for knowledge
we should listen to undergrads because they
can be a source of inspiration and new insights
for the rest of us we should partner with
communities truly partner not just show up
and try to do research that we think is for
their good their own benefit right and we can
only do that through their partnership really
if we're in like a helper role a service role
because of course we can't
solve social problems without
the help of the society we're trying to help
all right so here's some steps here's some
practical things that i hope participants in
this innovation lab and everybody can do will do
um to help establish ethical collaborations as
a cornerstone of collaborative research so first
of all we need a diverse team in every sense okay
expertise identity career stage experience all of
those things are going to make better knowledge
there are people who have expertise who study
how best to do team science people who belong
to the the science of team science discipline
they have a really wonderful website called
interreach which has some resources on how to
build an effective team especially in science
um there's there's some publications that
have come out of this movement that have
sort of practical guidelines for research
teams one from the national research council
and one from the national cancer institute
both of those are available freely online
so my role in most of my projects has been as
the social scientist on a team of scientists
and engineers and that is not enough that's
an important first step a lot of funders now
require a social scientist or an ethicist
to be on these large collaborative teams
but let me tell you it's not enough
one person alone can't ensure ethical
collaboration it's too it's too hard it's too
complex and so i would argue that instead of
having one facilitator i would train everybody in
facilitation skills okay there's lots of webinars
workshops where you can learn how to work
well with others rather than outsourcing
it to somebody else it's better if we all
do it together we all have skin in the game
and then finally most importantly we need to
practice trust respect and listening actually
do it not just talk about it so here are some
ways we can do that and one is to write a
memorandum of understanding um this lots of teams
do this sometimes it's pretty formalized and it's
deciding things like authorship and data sharing
who is it who is the leader who is responsible for
mentoring how do we handle complaints and so lots
of teams do this already and we should all do it
and we should follow it and we should
remember that it's a living document
that should be updated and we should it should
be a starting point for building consensus
throughout the life of the project so you can
google around and find examples for these in some
templates there's something called the contributor
roles taxonomy that i think is really helpful that
lays out all the kinds of work that are part of
scientific research and then helps you decide
how to label a contributor so beyond my list of
you know technicians and students and volunteers
it breaks it down more into like data
analysts versus data creators versus
data interpreters okay and then that can help you
figure out how people in your team fit together
and this should be obvious but we should respect
everyone's contributions with pay okay i talked
about volunteers a little bit and students who
sometimes work without pay we should pay everybody
for their time and intellectual property okay
so everybody's making an epidemic contribution
that should be recognized and that's going
to be different in different fields and
different contributors are going to want
different kinds of rec of um recognition
so that's going to be a discussion
among your teammates how do
how do people want to be recognized for their
contributions both of labor and of knowledge
and there are two documents that are based
on each other and they're lovely called the
collaborators bill of light bill of rights
these are written by scholars and digital
humanities and it's really about defining
the roles of collaborators and particularly
of student collaborators to how to and how to
avoid exploitation of various kinds of workers
and then of course inviting and responding to
feedback creating spaces for open communication
is a crucial part of team science um partly
this is to inspire reflection just like an
undergrad asking a question is going to make a
grad student stop and think through what they're
doing and that's good for the science and if
we invite reflection among our team members
then we're all going to stop what we're doing
and make sure that what we're doing fits what
we actually want to be doing what we should be
doing ethically and morally and epistemically
thanks
kaelin that was fantastic and it gives us so much
more to think about in broadening the ethics of
biosciences so much more broadly as we you know
you talked about you're working with uh you
know engineering teams going to remote locations
and working with you know local communities and
indigenous communities where and you mentioned
trust um which i think is just so important
because you know so many of these communities have
just been they've been exploited they you know
this is like okay now there's another group of
probably predominantly white people going to come
in and tell us how you know we should be living
our lives and they just after the umpteenth time
of this possibly over you know decades and decades
you know they're not going to be very trustful and
their people are going to come in and take their
collect their data points and go away and never
see the results of that again so i think that's
so important and it's it's important not only for
dealing with indigenous peoples um you know
wherever they are alaska or or hawaii or here in
north america but also in some of our biosample
um data uh communities that we go and get data
from so people with autism spectrum disorder
people with mental health disorders people with
you know other neurological um disorders or
other things we we tend to you know they're
they're sort of a means to an end right they're
going to get us the data point we want we're
going to go ahead and write great papers um so
i think that's just such an important statement
and i'm curious about your own experiences
with this what you have seen in terms of the
positive feedback you've possibly gotten from
you know the native alaskans uh in your own work
yeah thanks i really didn't even talk about
research participants and and indigenous data sets
are an amazing example of potential exploitation
and potential mutual benefit right if those data
are used appropriately respectfully um there can
be a lot of good that can come out of biomedical
collaborations with indigenous communities and kim
talber is a scholar in my field who writes about
indigenous data rights over biosamples and she
her arguments are fabulous on how to do that well
and so for us we're still sort of figuring out
how to best serve our partners in new chaotic
um you've i told you some examples of how
they've already sort of corrected our course
thank goodness and another project i did with
charlottesville residents is a little maybe a
better example of that which is sharp advocates in
charlottesville are pushing the city to build an
open data portal to share the city's data online
publicly yeah and so i was working with them to
try to figure out what that portal should look
like and what should be on it and who should be
in charge of it and and we came up with really
different goals between what the city wanted
and what the citizens wanted and what people who
didn't know anything about data wanted which was
me right i have no idea how to use open data sets
and except that i knew that they were a good thing
and so how do we make this this object this portal
work for the city with its concerns about privacy
and its concerns about democratic engagement
right open data can be a way to pull people in
and help people develop an argument for the need
for change and the data advocates who just wanted
all the data and wanted it now and the rest of
us who would like to learn what we can learn from
using these kinds of projects so yeah bringing
together all those different stakeholders um is
crucial for the success of the research and also
crucial for the success of addressing real social
problems like infrastructure like democratic
democratic engagement like government transparency
yeah i like that and i was also struck by your
comments about um inclusion of say undergraduates
in the research enterprise and i'm old enough now
myself to have seen a lot of people who are older
than me simply just flat out refuse to include
undergraduates as part of you know on an author
list just you know oh they're undergraduates
you know what do they know they were just
the pair of helping hands and so we don't need
to give them any sort of uh authorship credit
and in my own life i've tried to do that where
possible because like you know what's the harm
right in fact it's good right it's good for that
student it like helps them and you know one of
the things you know as somebody who's sat on a lot
of graduate um uh student you know uh admissions
committees is that one of the things we look for
is paging through their applications how many
papers have they published and if it's you know oh
they're not supposed to or no we don't allow them
you're denying them this wonderful you know ticket
to the research you know ticket to entry into the
research world that uh had you just given them
the authorship it probably would have gotten them
past the door so i don't know i i'm intrigued
by that and um i'm curious if you've got any
examples yourself or you know of anybody who
for example they were included on some early
paper and now they're like you know i don't know
they're a national you know they've got some big
award or they're now you know some superstar who
had that opportunity i don't know if that makes
any sense but uh yeah yeah no absolutely i think
that's another argument for equity and inclusion
that if students don't have papers they're not
going to get into grad school in engineering
at least like you're expected to have a paper
when you graduate undergrad and that's you have
to communicate that expectation to the pi so that
they'll put the undergrads on and so that they'll
rethink that assumption about oh undergrads don't
deserve to be authors you know or they'll plan
i've done this myself where i planned papers
that we're writing really for the benefit of
the undergrads like it's preliminary results for
example like we're not going to finish the study
while that undergrad is a student so let's write
up something now so that that student can be on it
and then we'll build on that paper in
the future and that's been great for me
right it forces me to get some papers
out the door um and then that student has
proof of the like incredible contributions
that they've made and i think a lot of people
you know i'm being a little facetious because of
course undergrads need a lot of training just like
anybody to do research well and but one of the
most valuable things i found about working with
undergrads is that they show up you know every
tuesday at one i'm gonna have a student in my
office who's gonna look at me really eagerly and
say what am i doing this week that's right which
keeps me on target and make sure that i've done
my part so that i don't disappoint the student
and that has actually been an incredible boon
to my own research just like the relentlessness
of it that you you want the undergrads
depending on you and so therefore you produce
and i think only undergrads could do
that if it were a collaborator i think
we wouldn't be as as quick you know we
wouldn't we don't meet every week with
our collaborators because we're off doing our own
things and so undergrads can provide that sort of
pressure slash support to keep going so absolutely
absolutely and undergraduates i've had in
my labs in various institutions um i've always
tried to give them those opportunities either to
you know present a poster at a big conference
or to you know have first author publications
on things that you know what's the harm it's no
harm to me i'm still an author right i'm just the
you know the guy at the end of the list right
but the per the people who are actually doing
the work you know give them that opportunity and i
had one student who i just thought the world of um
and i always tried to make sure that she had
opportunities to lead you know the writing of
papers and whatnot um at the this was while she
was kind of an undergraduate and kind of after
she had graduated but she was still working in
the lab um she ended up with enough peer-reviewed
publications of of herself that she was on uh
that her age index was like higher than some
of the junior faculty that we were considering
and she's now a great she eventually went to
grad graduate school herself and now she's
a graduate student but i always thought you
know gosh if we just were able to do that for
so many more students that would be wonderful
right and also as a recognition of the work
that they've done yeah just to help their career
but to like say thank you you know they earned
that absolutely and so one of the things about
the i guess bringing this back to ethical ai is
is as we're thinking about you know we collect
this data and we use it to build models and then
presumably we want to make predictions about like
i don't know where permafrost is melting more
quickly or what what have you and you're using
computational models on that how do some of these
ethical considerations map themselves if they do
it all into you know turning these things into
code or into mathematical models do you have any
sense about that yeah i do and i think ethically
ai is is scary because we think it's so technical
we got so so focused on the math and the coding
and the models and the predictive aspects and
it's easy to just say just build the thing and
we'll figure out who's responsible for it later
we'll figure out what your contribution was later
you know we'll figure out how we're going to share
this later and that's really dangerous that's
a way to exploit particularly junior research
members and you know underrepresented minorities
are going to bear the brunt of that discrimination
and so it worries me about ethical ai that
it's it's so people think of it as being so
technical and it's not like it's still a team
of people working together to build this thing
and so we need to respect that team as a sort of
living breathing organism that we need to sustain
and support and create governance structure for
and provide training and mentor you know what i
mean like all these things there has to be so much
learning on a team of people working on ethical ai
because it relies on so many disciplines and
so many kinds of knowledge and so yeah i gave
this talk bringing together a wide variety
of fields on purpose to make the point that
i think these these recommendations i'm making
are true for any field of research or design
well you certainly touched on one of the main
thrusts of our biomedical data science innovation
lab is to bring these different voices together
with different points of view and different
perspectives different backgrounds different
kind of sets of you know skill sets that they
can bring together because you know so often
uh how many times have we seen something where
i don't know a bunch of people just cut from the
same cloth get together and do something and then
say hey everybody look what we built you should
all want to use this or whatever it is and peop
people who are not within that you mentioned kind
of the outsiders right we'll take a look at it and
go i would never have done it that way and what
you've created is completely useless to me if you
had my input i might have been able to give you
some different you know more nuanced understanding
of this area and so anyway bringing all these
different voices together is is such an important
element of of research of ethical ai and certainly
part of our biomedical data science innovation
i'm so glad yes well um i think we're
about done caitlin wiley from university
of virginia thank you so much for sharing your
uh insights and wisdom and uh ideas about team
science and collaboration and what all that
means for ethical ai we really appreciate it
thank you thank you everybody
for for joining us and uh